hey youtubers is Charlie if you guys
didn't know they just confirmed the new
spider-man movie the reboot is going to
be called spider-man homecoming marvel
Sony all the big studios have been
making a bunch of big announcements at
CinemaCon it's kind of like a version of
comic-con
for theater owners so those screen
movies they'll show off trailers like
they showed off new Wonder Woman footage
they actually screened the entire whole
civil war movie that all the different
studios do a big Hall H type
presentation there
Sony flew Tom Holland in to make the
announcement hey this new spider-man
movie we're making it's called
spider-man homecoming it's coming out
July 2017 they haven't announced - the
villain is but the funny thing about
homecoming the title means a whole bunch
of things it's a big metaphor it's a
high school reference as in the
homecoming dance he's supposed to be 15
years old freshman in high school in
this first movie homecoming is also a
wink - spider-man coming back into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so it's like
he's coming home but the title
homecoming will also apply to the
villains storyline like the villain will
have a homecoming of sorts they haven't
confirmed who it is the Kevin Feige did
say that it would be a villain that we
have not seen in the spider-man movies
before - d confirm that Michael Keaton
will be playing him that's right Batman
is going to be the villain of the new
spider-man film no but seriously if he's
not gonna play Kraven there a number of
other big options he could be theirs
Mysterio
there's Morbius there's the jackal
there's moorland but that's more of a
multiverse character like that was a big
spider virtual on hold the phone though
what do you guys think about this he's
playing the vulture isn't that a great
idea I know it kind of seems silly
because he played Birdman but vulture is
an older character he's a more mature
gentleman so they're not gonna age him
down big time one of the younger Marvel
villains just another option but I feel
like vulture actually I'll say vulture
probably the strongest pick now they've
confirmed Michael Keaton they actually
dropped this news the Michael Keaton
news halfway through me making this
video so I had to back up a little bit
and I just love the idea that Batman is
gonna be the new villain is gonna be so
much fun making gifts for this the only
other big characters they've announced
is zendaya she's probably playing a
young version of Michelle Gonzales one
of the bigger protagonists slash love
interest for spider-man in the more
recent comics Mark Waid actually created
her she doesn't really become a
comic-book superhero or anything like
that the adult version of her character
just becomes this badass lawyer who
actually pretty good at Muay Thai so
even though they're both
Highschool they might give her some cool
fight scenes and I've talked about it
before but Marvel just clarified that
yes they will have Marvel characters
appearing in the Sony film like people
will crossover both ways so at least a
couple characters that do not die during
civil war will have cameos in the new
spider-man film probably Iron Man maybe
Captain America because I think they
changed the Captain America story from
the comics but the really funny thing
about Tom Holland this weekend he's a
total trooper they had the Captain
America Civil War Hollywood premiere
like they had the big red carpet
premiere so all those stars came out but
because Sony was doing their CinemaCon
presentation for this and they wanted
him for the unveiling they flew him down
from Los Angeles to Las Vegas for like
10 minutes then he turned right back
around and flew back to LA for the
after-party for civil war which is so
funny but everybody that got to see
civil war early last week said that he
is like the best version of spider-man
so far so now is the time to get hype
now I know he's got this really cool
stark tech suit in Captain America Civil
War he'll probably be wearing that
during the new spider-man film but they
did say that when they brought him back
for Avengers infinity war he would get a
new suit and the thing about that is you
have to remember there's gonna be three
new spider-man films they only have the
first one on the schedule I think they
want to see how well it does before they
greenlight the other two but it's going
to be a new trilogy so if the second or
third films happen after Avengers
infinity War part 1 we might see the new
costume in those spider-man films but
for the time being just assume that this
is what spider-man's costume is going to
look like this right here is the
official logo for the film you may
detected they're using like the classic
swoops in the original comic book
spider-man typeface like I said
homecoming he is coming home to Marvel
so there's gonna be a lot of classic
visual and verbal references to that but
let me know what do you guys think about
the homecoming title obviously it's a
big high school reference and for people
that live outside the u.s. homecoming is
just a traditional celebration that
schools organized for for high school
students people between the ages of 15
and 18 the whole idea was spider-man is
that he's just gonna age his way through
high school in this new trilogy so we're
gonna get a really young version of
spider-man which i think is totally fine
because that means if things go really
well or as well as they want them to he
can continue to be spider-man for a long
long time
the funny thing about people aging out
of the role I know Robert Downey jr. is
gonna be Iron Man until he's a corpse
he's gonna be like a walking corpse in
an Iron Man suit they actually said for
Civil War they
d aged Robert Downey jr. to a
twenty-year-old version of himself so
that they could do a 20 year old Tony
Stark scene this is what Robert Downey
jr. looked like when he was 20 years old
if you don't recognize this it's from
weird science
when Robert Downey jr. was about this
age a lot of the movies that he starred
in cast him as the douche bag character
try to guess how high he was on set
every day when he was playing this
character good times good times
speaking of which agents of shield had a
big WTF reveal so I'll do my agents of
shield video later tonight there's a
bunch of their comic book stuff that I'm
trying to get through so be sure to
subscribe to get everything what I'll
probably do is I'll do another Doctor
Strange video towards the end of the
week but there's some flash stuff
there's some arrow stuff I want to do so
there's a whole bunch of stuff going on
this week while you guys wait for me to
post that video you can click here to
watch the Doctor Strange trailer again
and you can click here for the big game
of Thrones trailer video I just did
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you